i want to start with congratulations you
guys are both fantastic in the movie um
i i'm making i'm going to start with a
little bit of a jokey question but you
guys shot the movie like two summers ago
have you been calling david being like
so we're going to see it soon right
yeah i'm not sure i was going to david i
was just more concerned that the movie
would come out and that the movie
would be released in theaters that's the
one of the biggest things because that's
how it was shot that's
why they they did it
um
so yeah i just you just want people to
be happy well you've got some really
interesting toys behind you don't you
uh yeah it's just it's a distraction you
know it keeps people from looking i'm
making a joke here
i mean to me i i've learned english in
these two years so
i'm pretty happy
um so one of the things that i think
that is important for people to realize
is that you do not have to have seen the
sopranos to watch this movie and enjoy
it it's a completely standalone
experience but if you've seen the
sopranos obviously you're going to get
more out of it can you sort of talk
about that for people that might not
know
yeah i think um yeah it stands by itself
for sure but if you still see the
sopranos i mean um
it's a trip but
i think it's a
great tribute for the sopranos you both
have some really good scenes together um
and i'm just curious what did you guys
uh learn about each other from filming
together because i've spoken to some
actors that like love a certain way of
working on set and others like it a
completely different way i'm just
curious what it was like working
together
to me it's been it's been a gift
to to me to meet dave um to meet
ray
i've learned a lot from him
honestly you know i loved working with
her just because she was committed she
doesn't she didn't back down she she
stood tall with the character that she
was playing
uh and that's good it's really really
fun to play to act uh
with somebody who's excited about doing
it i find it somewhat exhilarating about
playing pretend and the people who
really know how to play pretend
uh this movie has a lot that you can
talk about but what are you for for for
people that are going to go what are you
most excited for people to actually see
in the film
i don't know that they see
or just feel like that was money well
spent
you know you want people to have the
experience but you know you take away
your problems for a couple hours and
hopefully you just want them to be
entertained and like michaela said
before you don't have to see the
sopranos in order to appreciate the
movie
something else that's also very
interesting about the film is that it
doesn't follow like a typical movie
where it's just one character you know
beginning middle and end this is really
an ensemble piece with many different
story lines and many different
characters um i guess could you talk a
little bit about that i think i think
this is a
actor's movie and it's really really
rare i don't know if it's the word
but um
uh
yeah it's an it's an acting movie it's
something you know they're great actors
and
yeah as you said there's no
a main role
we are all
important
like well i already have to stop i'm
just going to say again you guys were
both fantastic in the movie hope it's a
huge hit thank you so much for your time
you